All right, to help me
with today's exam,
please welcome our new
nightly show optics expert,
real-life eye surgeon
and Kentucky senator Rand Paul.
(cheers and applause)
All right.
Welcome to the show, Rand.
Have a seat.
(cheers and applause)
Our crowd. Oh, yeah.
Thank you. Thank you.
Thanks. Uh, thanks
for taking the time
to be on our... our... being
our Nightly Show optics expert.
Okay, so, uh, I mean, I assumed
you'd be too busy
with the presidential debates.
And I'm gonna be,
like, a correspondent, right?
Uh, Larry, you're breaking up
a little bit. Could you...?
-WILMORE: No, no, no,
you're sitting right here. -No?
Oh, I'm right here
being the... Okay.
WILMORE: Yeah. Exactly.
Uh, okay, so...
(laughs)
So, now,
as an eye surgeon, uh...
uh, what's your take
on Donald Trump?
-(laughter)
-Well, you know, Larry,
have you ever had a speck
of dirt fly into your eye?
Yeah, I mean,
that's really annoying, yup.
-Yeah.
-Mm-hmm.
Annoying, irritating.
Might even make you cry.
(laughter)
Sure. Sure.
I'm with you.
-But if the dirt doesn't go
away... -WILMORE: Mm-hmm.
...it'll keep scratching away
at your cornea
until it eventually blinds you
with all its filth, and then,
it makes fun of you on CNN.
(laughter)
Think you got a little personal
in there, uh...
I got it. So you're saying
the eye is a conservative voter,
and Donald Trump is
the speck of dirt, right?
-No, Larry.
-WILMORE: Uh-uh?
Donald Trump is
a delusional narcissist
and an orange-faced windbag.
-(laughter and groaning)
-WILMORE: Huh.
(applause and cheering)
WILMORE:
Yeah?
A speck of dirt is way
more qualified to be president.
-(applause and cheering)
-Well said.
Our new correspondent,
Rand Paul, everybody.
Thank you.
Thank you. You're breaking up
a bit, Larry.
-WILMORE: No, you don't have
to do that. -Oh, I'm sorry.
Well, thanks for having fun
with us.
Do you have time to answer
a couple questions, actually?
That-that was very good.
Did you have fun doing it?
If... Are they easy... easy
questions? -Very easy questions.
-All right, all right.
-Uh, this is very easy.
Why are you running
in the Republican Party?
I don't understand that.
I mean, you're pro-weed.
-Uh, you're like...
-No, no, no.
-I'm just not anti-weed.
-No, you're pro-weed. You're...
No, no, no,
I'm just not anti-weed.
-No, no. No, no, no, no, no.
-Okay. Whatever you say.
You-you help people
with their glaucoma.
-You're pro-weed, right? Okay.
-(laughter)
Anti-prison industrial complex.
You've talked, uh, very
eloquently about prison reform.
Is there, like, a middle ground
-of people that you're looking
for... -Well...
...that aren't Republican,
aren't Democrat?
Are there people in there?
Like, huge...?
There are people from both sides
that we're trying to get.
Yeah. Okay.
From the right, there are people
who believe in economic liberty.
From the left, there are people
who believe in personal liberty.
And really what we're trying
to do is join liberty together
to say, you know what?
Across the board,
-government ought to stay out
of your life. -WILMORE: Uh-huh.
Jeb Bush said he'd go back in
time and kill baby Hitler, okay?
Um, would you go back in time
and stop baby Trump
from being born?
(laughter)
You know, I'm not sure I would
say that Trump is Hitler.
-Goebbels maybe.
-WILMORE: I'm not saying that.
Goebbels maybe,
but I'm not saying Hitler.
-I'm not going there.
-Really? So, you're really...
You're going there, then.
No, no, no.
I've said he wasn't Hitler.
-WILMORE: No, you just went
there. -No, no, no, I...
I steadfastly said he was
not Hitler, but maybe Goebbels.
But I have seriously
compared him to Gollum
from The Lord of the Rings.
Yes, I understand
where Gollum is from, right.
-You know, "My precious."
-Yes.
You know, the ring,
the ring of power.
That's very scary what
you just did, by the way.
-Yeah, I know. I know.
-(laughter)
-But what I've been trying
to tell people... -Yes.
-What worries most
about Trump... -What is that?
...other than all
of the other crazy things
is that I believe that
he wants power, and I believe,
from my point of view,
that power corrupts,
and that the whole purpose
of our founding fathers
and our country was
to contain power.
The Constitution was to restrain
the size of government...
-WILMORE: Mm-hmm.
-...and keep power at a minimum.
And I don't want power
to gravitate
to a Republican or a Democrat.
-Yes, go ahead.
-(applause and cheering)
You are certainly
your own candidate.
You don't... you don't seem
to follow any side.
You follow your own path, and
I think that's really something.
All right, are you ready
to play Keep It 100?
To answer
a Keep It 100 question?
-That. Okay.
-(applause and cheering)
-PAUL: Was I really good
at this game? -Yes. No.
-You have to do this.
-Oh, yeah.
You have to keep your answer
100% real.
Ready? Okay,
other than Donald Trump--
you can't mention Trump, okay--
who is the biggest dick
of all the GOP candidates
right now?
And I know you have an answer.
Larry, I think
you're breaking up here.
-Um, can you, uh, help us,
uh...? -WILMORE: Who is it?
-Come on. Who is it?
-(audience shouting out)
You know, before...
Just say Ted Cruz. Just say it.
He's the biggest tool, right?
Just say,
"Ted Cruz is a tool, Larry."
-Yeah.
-Just say that.
-See, before we came on here...
-Just say, Ted Cruz is a tool.
Please, just say it. Just
say it, damn it! Just say it!
Before we came on here...
-Before... before... -WILMORE:
Just say Ted Cruz is a tool.
-Ah.
-Rand Paul, everybody!
00:04:46,052 --> 00:00:00,000
-That's all we got.
-(applause and cheering)